the community helps a former strip
entertainer get mobile again
after a bad deal when trying to upgrade
his motorized scooter
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
joins us live in the newsroom tonight
with more on the effort kristin sasha
raymond streibe relies on a mobile
scooter to get around it's his
transportation after suffering from
two strokes in one day but he's parked
at home right now following a bad trade
online and
the community wants to help him get
around again
i'm stuck an issue for the normally
self-sufficient raymond stribe
a former strip entertainer who surrounds
himself at home
with the memories comedy and music
that's all i did his life changing 14
years ago after suffering two strokes in
one day
the now 64 year old continues recovering
from certain disabilities
including speech issues while relying on
a mobility scooter to get around
for me that's a life
you know that's my thing no
he made a trade online and paid 800
dollars to try and upgrade his scooter
from this one
to this one seeking more comfort and
speed
but soon learned it was a bad deal after
the scooter stopped working
it's 11 and i didn't know he was taken
advantage of because
he couldn't contact the seller anymore
he made multiple attempts
that perfect janice aranas is striped
speech pathologist
she started a gofundme three weeks ago
to help her client of more than 10 years
whatever we can get we will obviously
make sure ray is taken care of and he
has the transportation he needs
donations from the community and friends
keep coming in to help strive
meet his goal they're just very
supportive and want to get him back on
his feet
back to also living life independently
again
this gives him that freedom to do the
things that he enjoys
i want to go out
stripe lives in an apartment and says
his caretaker has graciously driven him
to therapy the last three weeks and
helped with other errands now he warns
others to stay cautious about making
deals
with strangers online and i want to
report that i just looked at that
gofundme and it seems he has succeeded
his goal reporting live in the newsroom
kristen drummond
8 news now